[Music]
welcome podcast and we are live welcome
to the iron Lords podcast episode number
77 it's another glorious Sunday we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
I'm very excited about our special
patreon I guess so we're gonna get right
into it I want to introduce the Lord who
was not only a fellow og when it comes
to his gaming history but also has the
technical acumen to break it all down
behind the scenes initially the owner of
the most dangerous tech blog in the
brown this Lord has recently made the
transition to the vlog space all done
with brutal honesty raw gaming opinions
and it's completely self-made
introducing the host of optimist code
dotnet and ruler of the real gaming
nation the lord of coding and software
development who always good blames the
axe while dropping nothing but facts
into the realm of the lord's mommy Lord
optimist code are you doing sir we could
talk about this for a while get in the
round some og gaming talk it's always
welcome in the round table so it is a
pleasure to have you here man
man you already know and of course we
have the four horsemen of gaming those
usual suspects at the round table
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the half of the young
whoops mommy
Lord addict are you doing sir I'm doing
pretty good
playing some destiny before I got on the
show you got that game vide you got data
gap it's fun it's fun I've been playing
a lot of that fan and doctrine game - yo
we gonna get into that old my turn oh
thank you for telling me how to do
overwatch in that game you know what's
funny what's up I'm probably about 15
hours in the game and I think I've shot
my gun twice yo you know what's crazy is
so stealth oriented I like it's funny
because I was gonna tell solve about it
but love this game because it's XCOM but
it's really not it's like stealth right
it's more you don't have to kill it it
actually still your benefit not to you
know saying do all like the craziness
you know what I mean
but anyway so that's what you've been
playing yeah they're just pretty much
those two games
I've been definitely you know pretty
much if I'm not doing that
I'm on Twitter talking to people about
the spider-man downgrade game who lives
with the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra darkness
mr. offline profile luminary and Lord
patreon of the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign how you doing sir I am
doing fantastic great good playing a lot
of stuff this week we're gonna get into
paying our bills after everybody does
the intros I'm gonna come back around
and pay the bills so that our patreon
guys are taken care of so see what I've
been playing on the PlayStation has been
dormant you know it's coming out of
dormancy this week on my xbox I play
something again but yesterday that
that's crazy fun is really it's got
Saabs approval it's not my yeah is it's
it's a fun mode what it keeps you
running around like a madman it's very
like I enjoy it um let me see I place a
Master Chief collection got in there to
see how upgrades
beautiful beautiful and now that it's
in-game past all of a sudden you see the
games being populated again you can play
when you have a stream of us playing
like something about going after you
play destiny for a little bit and then
you come hallo old man halen Destiny
helps you a little bit let's just say
that I was getting both made by the same
watch oh my god hang them high upgrade
it just prettier unfortunately it's not
running at 60 but it's still pretty Iran
that's which man I finally played the
messenger gating style 16/8 I download a
play it starts out 8-bit like really
simple then you start getting more like
more pop more powers and like most
maneuverability and you feel like a
ninja and then it goes left beautiful
it's funny it is it's kind of self
referential in a way like it it just
makes fun of a lot of by gamey tropes
really yeah it's funny it has some
comedy elements that are really cool and
then the game that I mentioned to you
privately is into the breach man into
the breach into the Marines came out it
kind of landed like a thud mm-hmm when
that went that in the the nin DS direct
that one more thing because yes a person
if you're not a person that paying
attention to the the PC scene you didn't
realize that this game was sort of big
at the beginning of the year and the PC
just it wasn't so that one more thing
kind of like if you don't know
what it is like okay whatever yes not
those in the chat he said he loved it it
is RTS distilled down to its simplest
form it's not like XCOM where and it's
calm like I'm fighting the next
competition like a half hour or whatever
like one battle like this is distilled
down to simple like one board
it's basically Pacific Rim that's what
it is like that's know you know it felt
like a really good game that was I
thought it was like overlooked I had
that kind of finding stuff with those
massive chalice hardman breach man into
the breach you playing our normal you
getting destroyed like and I'm not the
RTS guy but I think it's perfect for the
switch
yeah and it's it's a great game no doubt
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka x-gamer ooh
the lord of combat sports was a man of
his convictions demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert move it Oh
beloved
my king how you doing sir we are doing
fantastic today we got one more week
foil incredible fight Shawn Porter
versus Danny Garcia be coming on next
Saturday
okay fight season now summer time is
over bump season is done you know tomato
can land is over we got to step up
fights we got dudes mixing it up yo so
you will have a study preffer of combat
talk going all the way through I think
every weekend from here until probably
December to be honest with you with some
big fights coming in December as well
they're trying to get a Mikey Garcia
versus arrow Sprint's which i think is a
massacre on paper
be honest with you um but oh I wanted to
say one thing I wanted to say if you're
not following LOCOG nito's twitter I
think you should if you're looking at
work out things he like you go to gym
you looking around you don't know really
what to do what you do is follow the
LOCOG needles twitter key posts every
day what like body part that he's
working on I've been
telling him this is where the fraud
police is coming in the Senate Oh Lord
kognito look with the fraud stamp he
thought it was coming for something else
is coming for this um the fraud stamp is
going on Lord Cardinal today because he
posed Oh keV did my calf raises ha ha
and he out right but you got a lot of
people that want to understand like how
you did you can have breakdowns and
stuff like that they do actually look at
you because when I do retweet it is so
many retweets and likes on it that they
want to know what you're doing with your
curls what you're doing with your back
and stuff like that so yeah I'm calling
law I'm calling Florida law kognito on
neck the fro police out there for you
dude I'm getting a little um a little
alert I'm not gonna call too many y'all
out because it was a whole crew y'all
they showed up on destiny yesterday like
[Applause]
what I need is I need to join oh my
mother shut out alright y'all in I got
no problem with that it's funny how
y'all waited to win gambit was on that
you showed up Klan wants you to Klan one
should we take you oh but then we had
serve people that don't normally play
destiny he shouted he came in and listen
I really wasn't playing that Boyd
yesterday because I did it and I did it
III with the new supers so when we was
playing it with these old supers it felt
kind of off like uh like Eminem's album
kamikaze I felt kind of all because the
boy the bars are definitely there I
don't think his production is dead
shoutout J Fonzarelli he was kind of
like an old dude with his to step off
not J but em real real quick you know so
Soglin got in there and he was mixing it
up same thing to his brother
they got in and they were working with
the 18 now he sees it kind of different
when he's playing with us then he's when
he's playing with the a team I know tat
with shout now Matt go do this and do
that let's do this crazy these guys knew
exactly what they were doing it's funny
because it was only out for like an like
an hour and these guys knew with the
strategy and everything listen um I
cannot wait for this week because is it
our taking King I truly believe so
I truly but I love the direction where
everything is going they do yes yes so
for those people that was talking
destiny dad talk go get the shovels go
back to your backyard go dig it up and
come right back in here salute applause
a moment to chat one of the newest
members of IOP he's like oh man man let
me know and I'm like okay he said he
didn't have a clear line and Xbox is
trying to get me to go on and play
destiny to on PlayStation some of them
don't even have an Xbox to play it on
now so they have to play it on
PlayStation and Merc doesn't even have
destiny on Xbox city boards so he has to
play it on I'm not playing it on I will
agree with that I do I prefer Sony's
controller Dualshock for fighting age
like that's when I love it yeah the
thing I don't play fighting is at all
shinobi lord kognito spreading their
wings in the realm of the ILP not
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear so for me it's
just been on it's been destiny - I did
the the gambit more I got
only two games and I mean crazy busy and
shout the Attic [ __ ] like I said we
talked about it earlier fandom doctrine
y'all like if you got where's deaf thing
is deafening in the chat all you XCOM
loves if you don't pick up this game
shoutout to create afford studios good
shepherd entertainment that game listen
little rough around edges graphic we
couldn't put that out there right now it
was it they had a budget you know i'm
saying that they wanted the most likely
needed to have to go all the way with it
but it is up rest of 4k is really
phenomenal man it's literally like XCOM
you know a rainbow succeeds and like us
a true whole school spy game you know
what I mean it's so much fun and it like
like attic said you don't have to really
fight but you you you can get through
situations and it's crazy like it's
basically set in the Cold War you got
agents you would like a little secret
agency trying to fill out like a whole
cuz our government conspiracy you know
yeah ages could get made you gotta give
them new identities passports and all
that like the game is fire it's calm and
the music is amazing I get sets the time
piece you want some more you know
Casablanca tight did you play Doran
dandera no I know I it's I kind of I
know what it is right it's that funky
like platformer right it is probably
isn't game pass right now so anybody has
game players I please implore that you
go and download this game it's not
16-bit type of game 30g it's this
perfect for the switch to be honest but
it's a young african-american girl with
superpowers
yes something like that movement you can
go anywhere you go up down left right
anyway is multilateral caucus he's
asking odd is it being down we gotta get
the name for me please
ara yes
alright we got you we got you uh your
hands out there you go it is probably
one of these sleeper games I was
surprised that it was in game
I saw at Microsoft like some of Indies
yeah and it's in-game past and I
automatically downloaded it I just want
I wanted to say it last week and it just
slipped off my mind but I started
playing it again and I was like y'all
was talking about this other game and I
just really wanted to get that out to
everybody like how you playing something
on a low it's that damn fresh out the
frog frog say yeah he's cool
Oh chief um yes come is good we got
shout out we got lost Naldo on the alpi
youtube channel he got a whole preview
of that about our gameplay please check
that out if you want to check out scum
that come those guys from devolver
digital our man they out here and we saw
we had a chance me and King had a chance
to sit with it dance all type of stuff
you can do it put it this way you can do
number one and number two we so yeah the
last game for me with just like soft
Master Chief collection dusted it off is
so good to see you know say and it's
there for 60 that HDR looking crispy you
promised a shout out to Kofi I was
putting them on because he didn't think
he could have it until on afterwards but
I was like now if you already had the
old one
you're good I had a schedule so he's
rocking that shine out what you can do
intelligent delivery and break down the
downloads for only the ones you want or
the multiplayer you want which is very
cool so shout out to send me something
that game like the plague so if you want
to get into it you get it - before we
got up we get it to code yeah absolutely
that time of the month you can't take
care of our patreon subscribers these
wonderful people that help us do what we
do
weekend and week out so we much
appreciate it um just a disclaimer to
all if those personal payments to my
PayPal account have not arrived yet
yourself out of the running
I'm talking to you brother
let me get all of our patreon
subscribers so let's start out with Lord
whiskey himself thank you sir remember
fireball followed by the PlayStation
brah thank you my brother
oh yeah my Brahman see you next year
brother then of course Lord Michael Liu
goes in the chat Illinois let's go thank
you so much and the lord of back compat
himself mr. bill still with and our
newest patreon subscribers Lord Ricky
Moore thank you so absolutely thank you
for coming on um and then of course our
power buddy Lord irrelevant native oh
thank you my brother
boy we love you man thank you yes my pop
G do Lord spoon man thank you so much
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
fantastic if you don't listen to Francis
concert you don't watch this content
goes video the best oh I love this music
[Music]
by the king of the street team Lords now
doh
[Laughter]
followed by last but absolutely not
least our honored guests today Lord
optimist respect one absolute pleasure
to have you here thank you for all the
support you've given us from the very
beginning we much appreciate it from all
of you guys hold on a second guys
Delilah I got you when I get on the day
you won't be on destiny I'm gonna add
you just like I had everybody else but
we got beyond see because a lot of these
dudes they be adding from the phone I'm
not having that on my phone I got too
much alerts popping in from other stuff
so i'ma jump and see you physically
there's like a real job and you know
it's a new job you coming in
I'm give you the application you'll sign
the paperwork we'll squared up a fraud
these women scare now does this get into
the business quickest get into these
giveaway
so we're gonna start off with our $10
gift card giveaway and that first one
goes Lord monkey punch my conspiracy bro
what do you got that you got that $10
that $10 gift card my colugo thank you
for that payment to that paper on $20
gift card goes to Lord spoon man boom is
my guy I'll get you that info you'd be
em soon and the winner of our ILP
t-shirt today that we'll go to that's
what's up let me let me get a little
coat oh yeah we own that real quick King
cup of t-shirts I'm like man you got
t-shirts with the big guys he said man
i'ma having a little bit right now we
got his like 2x so be sure for everybody
in the family know that no I told you we
was up to 3x I got that 3x yes and that
was the thing because we keep it our
check on
we're gonna roll thank you lord code we
roll we roll here we go let's go
so the winner of the t-shirt this week
is month is Lord J on your head with the
road yeah thank you so much for your
ongoing support we really appreciate it
so now we got into the iron bank and
what the Lords have been playing I want
to start off with Lord optimist coal his
video game system history his journey as
a software developer for over 30 years
and of course would let him to create in
the most dangerous vlog it was cool
let me tell ya I gotta be safe out there
let's start from the beginning what
let's start with some OG game talk what
was some of the first video game systems
you had and what got you baby
well actually before we do that real
quick real quick sure he said we had a
big fight coming up this week I thought
he was talking about his spider-man God
of War battle with that it was like I
wonder what game King's gonna buy me I
believe addicts started their whole
spider-man total nonsense and I think if
you trace the route source of the thing
it will go to his broad account that it
has only one that'll be next month one
of MPD's roll
what kind of gotcha ignore the first
game jam like I told y'all before I
don't know who all been paying attention
but I'm 54 years old so literally out
solutely
first like palm literally was the radio
game that I was hooked
yes from day one everyone had that pong
that's what's up now on now as far as
like all from a console so you start I'm
assuming also you
you went from there to arcade did you
stay console like give me the genesis of
that well I've seen it at a friend's
house and so then I had to cut grass and
all this stuff to try to give one on my
own but then while I was trying to build
up my funds to get my own Atari of
course I went to the arcade that's baby
toys basically in the arcades until I
got one at home no doubt baby everybody
put on gchat right that respect we
appreciate that
so now as far as like once she saved up
and everything so like would you get the
2600 like what was the first from your
bread your money that like this consoles
mine yeah all right and then from the
errors all fall forward like most like
some of the systems that you had our
from that point you just kind of had
everything yeah I've always had
everything after that there is yeah I
believe in gaming
wherever the games are and I refuse to
restrict myself at all that's the moji -
I respect that man and like I would say
I guess the question for you because you
had
everything let me ask you a different
question like as far as like on the
errors like obviously we had AP narrator
yes you know saying it's a Master System
you know moving the 16-bit you know I
mean terrible Genesis Super Nintendo you
know which errors from back in the day
do you consider like you're not like
hip-hop we have the golden era
what's the golden era for the lower code
I want your perspective on that the
golden era of gaming for me for you man
that's a tough one
stuff right yeah yeah I mean cuz
obviously when I first started when I
got my first computer it when it really
opened up because they had stuff on a
computer that I wouldn't even dreamed of
on a console and I'm gonna have to go
ahead and say probably that 16-bit yeah
yo that was it for me too it was so
special because you had a hungry Sega
you know fresh off the mass system let's
call it a L you know as much as I'm a
Sega kid did 10 NES was running these
streets and es was fantastic and then
the see them so aggressive with Genesis
rice off it was like a rebirth you know
what I'm about to say we had the 16-bit
everything the graphics weren't arcade
perfect yet right so we still had that
marketing element Daniel what are you
going with SIA so that's when a quarter
meant something that's when you had a
pocket full of rockets those quarters
okay you put your quarter up on that you
look tell me about that experience your
arcade experience because you holding up
just like me to understand that feeling
walking in I live in a campus town and
rke right on in a hearty campus called
spaceport I mean it was packed right so
you go there and I remember when they
brought out miss pac-man legendary for
whatever reason I was able to let's say
get there early and so I learned a
couple of the routes and I was going
through doing my thing and of course
right around seven to eight o'clock at
night is when you really need to be
there yeah home you know did some stuff
came back to the arcade the line was
long slam our quarter levine will ever
read the man I was just in a groove and
I got to like I don't know like maybe
twenty levels in off of that one life
like the crowd was around me and it was
old father talk about it yeah and it was
just like man people look at him like
man what does this do cuz eat so when
you live in a college town if you from
the town they call you a townie it's a
clear difference between the kids that's
here to go to school and the kids that's
here because they live here right and
because of my background and my
appearance it was obvious that I was not
a student we're really stunned that a
townie could get this far game that
required like all of his prowess and
skill and so it was just like the crowd
was growing I was really I was like the
underdog you know I was gone and
basically that night is when I submitted
myself and miss pac-man and I put you
could you could put in three letters for
your initials and that stood there for
like I don't know like seven eight
months man I was taught in this cuz the
thing about somebody's my psycho right
now I don't know who's that going borova
dig up there go so the thing about it is
what code is saying it is so true is
like the arcade experience from now
only the competitive to players
experience then it's the one player
because you only had to be like so like
locota say it's a display of skill to
stay on one right just keep going and be
able to put your knee and then that stay
that means you own that spot like when
people came to that game when it was
booted up and they chose the first thing
that boots up times a minima high scores
yeah yeah oh who's that car who's that
like and I know what you mean like how
you talk about with the Townies and all
that stuff that reference because it's
like also like where we from I remember
my first many people know obviously
Laura kognito a shinobi that's where it
came from like shinobi was game for me
and I'd never remember I always forget
they're kicking coal 167th and there was
a kid he played that game and people he
was so good at shinobi like people would
crowd around him yeah yeah at the end
like he beat it and he put Dawn
[Applause]
[Laughter]
fantastic Dragon's Lair is dragons so we
all have each one of us all have a one
game that we are very very very good at
unbeknownst to Laura Cognito my game was
Strider little secret is only just us
and the 61 people watching them like
right this is how I suckered little he
went and he spent seventy nine fifty for
his his cartridge that was what it was
it was 30 to make the first bid for the
Sega Genesis strider home release
basically arcade perfect almost yes he
put it in and he was like oh you know he
was gracious cuz he was the host and I
was in the house and he passed me to
controller and with that one guy
and I into his game I said I I'm gonna
go home now catch you later
[Laughter]
violated a lot of principles that day is
when back in those days when you bought
a game and you came back to the house
with a single play again showcasing your
game rule number one was you could not
clown that man who purchased that game
because you laughter you what is called
especially we bought a new console and
bring it over your friend's house like
that's a problem I go let me show in our
friend board over like a Jaguar
and he was nice to keep it together
laughs we first like we said it wasn't
about that life but the thing were king
violate the other rule which is again
which is that your day one purchased you
let your friend play finish so the only
revenge I got on here was Neo Geo fatal
fury salute to Andy Bogart and that
cheesy elbow that I read I got it I got
it I got it
wait I got a prefixes with this it
wasn't day one I had brothers $250
cartridge the card is not the system all
right and I'm in my house playing this
game and I can't get past two guys the
boss was dead I'm telling Cognito I said
this is artist hell I don't think I'm
ever gonna get past this pristine
Cognito ba ba Devo garden for those who
don't know fatally shot the phone cuz he
yet I think he had a fake fury gamer pic
word tub is Terry Bogard any bro got the
brothers and the one brother and he just
had this cheap move it was like back
forward and it was an elbow and you can
literally cheese this but move on all of
the bosses so literally I got
let me try beautiful Oh baby take it
back right there so um obviously you
know the heiress what you said 16-bit
arrow definitely agree with the I agree
with you for sure
so um I just want to talk about what you
know for which is low north cold the
software developer like as a fellow IT
lord I dry cold and I'ma be honest
really like I found out quickly
I wasn't out for life so salute you or
dad so tell us about how you kind of
transition into the curry aspect well I
mean obviously the video games like is I
was playing video games what I loved is
what I did and I was like how how do you
do this like what's the name of this job
mmm back then my program is what is
prevalent as it is now it was rare to be
a programmer and so I started just
looking around and egm magazines what is
the name of this job and eventually I
was put on the programming and so that's
what I started I started on my own at
first I started getting better and
better
no actually there the here's an
interesting fun fact that's gone I
really got into programming for
videogames and I got together and
remember I took I'm at a college town so
I got together with the group of
students and we wanted to make a video
game and we how much of the story cannot
tell making a video game but I learned a
lot of lessons in that we went through
issues with publishers and different
developer contracts mmm understand NDA
at the time we made our new learn
document we left it with another company
they stole our idea they made like
almost exactly like
I don't often can you can you say what
the game was that they made so from that
though we ended up getting a publisher
way too late we lost our momentum and we
were still using sprites we have 3d
sprites but they were still sprites and
quake it came out with the first polygon
characters so everybody was switching
the polygon characters we finally
released the game like two years late
and so everybody the team basically just
twenty people that's watching a cat
daddy was to ask also like would Cassie
if you were like formally schooled or
self-taught in the coding area arenas
both so I started out on my own I went
to school for it and I finished school
for it because I started working he kept
me in the workplace offering me more and
more money programming is the type of
thing where if you have a high aptitude
for it you can pretty much do whatever
you need to do and it's like hold you
back because an axe it's a display of
skill and if you understand it you can
out call people with five or six degrees
that don't matter if you have the other
I fear you man I say so then kind of
like after that experience did that kind
of transition your sour you to the
industry based on you know saying this
game out there stealing al ideas and you
know let me let me just tell y'all so as
much as I can
go they'd not let me go they said at
least say the type of game I'm sorry
well it will so we was one of the first
ones to do a third person with the
camera over the shoulder game that was
our cousin I know nobody had done it yet
they in the 3d setting with a baby
surprise order basically the
third-person view is what we had come up
with what we was doing we wanted the
publisher since we were so new we didn't
have any background in the gaming
industry we wanted to show the
publishers that we really knew what we
was talking about the Lee explained all
of this stuff in our design document in
the game that ended up like stealing our
idea is only three initials in the game
so that the name of the game is bump
bump bump is just three letters in the
whole name
the first letter is an M and the last
letter is the K our little rip but we
still so here's the interesting story
though that ain't even an interesting
story the interesting story is that once
we saw that like they beat us to market
and we took us a while to finish the
game we went from publisher to publish
and we finally got it published by
Bandai I think was who ended up
publishing it and so the team split up
and our one of our main texture guys he
was a kid graduated from the University
his name was Chicago hmm and he moved up
to Chicago people like you know come up
to Chicago we need programmers because I
programmed all of the AI in our game mmm
I was responsible for all of the a are
they patterns and all of this stuff
and he was like man we need programmers
up here they'll pay you good but I've
been move up to Chicago because I had a
lot of ties here family church those
types of things and he and so moved up
to Chicago I mean he kept sending me
emails he kept calling me they need an
AI guy so on and so forth I didn't come
the name of the company that he went to
go work for I want to hold on one second
let's go coming ended up relocating to
California they would accompany with
bungee we made was halos I'm not kidding
and a lot of the AI patterns that you
see in halo was ideas the Chicago from
our game that he brought the Bungie and
that's not able trying to get me on
board if you look in our game the name
of our game is called SOT reah and
you're looking at you'll see the enemies
you see the guy with the riot shields
mm-hmm
try to work together and groups may be a
coordinated attacks it was like for us
and we could have got published we
really probably would have made a mark
on the industry but you didn't know what
we were doing the business side of
things is what does this give you and
then of course they went made destiny so
I hear y'all talk all this destiny stuff
and like Chicago head of art at Bunyan
I'm not sure he's but like the last
couple of years he was fell out of touch
it's all y'all destiny stories always
make me think like man I should have
went up to Chicago cut out a video yeah
you a king Beckman from anyway you want
somebody my bad no you go yeah
technically I'm selfish right now
because if you would have went to
Chicago we want to get this interview
I'm gonna be selfish right now oh and by
the look of you outset in the back he
hurts cash
quite well but if you do quite well for
yourself I don't know if you pushing a
Ferrari or something like that good
[Laughter]
absolutely no this is so crazy because
it's like again it just shows you you
know how paths can change you don't say
and just as far as the industry so like
as far as like that AI cuz that's one
thing that we have to give Bungie a
little credit like you know that their
games are know especially Halo right
those games are known for fantastic as
what kind of set it up you show the cat
daddies we need reparations is one of
those things like now did you think
about it like what you don't you know
these things like I know you said like
maybe I can felt away what about your
people like are they still in the game
are they like how what what are those
guys up to
oh yeah I've got yeah so pretty much
everybody on that team went out to do
big things was successful when our lead
developer he ended up working
he became the lead developer for THQ I
think he did be incredible he did a
bunch of licensed games so he did really
well for himself
one of our other guys our low-level guy
the low-level guy was who would do
everything in assembly and he worked
with the goes back then there were
multiple 3d cards and everybody was
fighting for that space to see him and
back then it was 3d effects it was the
last video card and so he was the guy
that would just do all the low-level
stuff to get framerate and a resolution
up to speed and he ended up going over
to he's the lead developer for a rocket
League I think but he'll know a lot of
things then I've got quite a few people
who work for Sony they did like the Star
Wars online they did a couple of people
that work with an eID right now Andy
Chang he did like dune to this latest
dune not being some sorry dune 3 this
latest dude he works for it so a lot of
their titles he does
then I got a couple of people who work
behind the scenes in producing nice and
who try to stay in touch like every two
or three years we might some email to a
group chat or something that's what's up
and it's tremendous stories this is
crazy
and I know you I know you doing
fantastic right now you're not hurting
right now but I want to ask you like if
the right bag came across from certain
death would Lord Cole be tempted you
know into some able to triple a
quadruple a space somebody answer that
question honestly and the answer is no
and it's not because of the so it's not
because I don't have the love for it but
it's a long time ago with the
development process there's this thing
called crunch time which basically means
you have to put in all these hours mmm
if there's deadlines coming up and got a
hit gold master it like all any stuff
you have to do and it requires a lot of
effort from the development team and I
quickly realized like you said I'm not
hurting and I have been less you know to
achieve a certain amount a financial
success but at the end of the day why
would I work 80 hours to get the same
money and get in fresh cream and I'm not
glad you said that unless game industry
the amount of overtime that's required
and too much for me so no I'll stay
where I'm at ha listen I feel and I'm so
glad you said that
just from the stem cuz a lot of gamers
don't understand that crunch I'm glad
you said that when a game before it goes
live there's that window right in its
cold time you had your life is that game
and nothing but that game in this it's a
I don't say all experiences or companies
it's a bad experience but you know I've
heard the horror stories I've seen some
people who tell me and you know training
break it down to me so you're just
saying that actually brings it back to
light and that's when I said I knew I
wasn't built for that but to hear you
say kind of validates that that's was so
yeah so I would like to you know get the
glory of having
a triple-a title let's go wanna put in
the work to get that it's real it's
whether you want to be successful you
know I get it man
I completely understand and if you're
gonna do better you know and you stay
under the radar
you still y'all got that stress in your
life I'm with that red yeah absolutely
so last day what ass look cuz this is
funny cuz I'm pretty much when came
across you channel you know saying in
access to see challenge nor sight let me
get that correct miss Cole got neck and
I'm saying for those don't know you know
mean you kind of like you doing things
your own way which I love it to unique
spins you need take its hardcore but you
had something on there called the real
gamer protocol broke it down so clean so
for those uninformed let me just break
it down let how help me break down now
we got you said it's the casual yeah
hobbyist
yeah and the real game right break it
down we got to know where some of these
Lords might have to put some fraud
alerts out there King there we go let's
break down the real game of protocol
don'ts for categories to let the people
well basically if you ask the question
and it's a serious question like what is
a gamer and a lot of people would say
like the hardcore gamer and I was like
what does that mean to be a hardcore
gamer and they will say hardcore versus
casuals and those are the two categories
but like I said in a video this woman
that I used to work with she was a beast
at solitaire which was a game you could
get on a Windows PC any time you bought
a Windows PC you wanted out here was it
my sweetie was hardcore at solitaire
like nobody was dedicated to that game
the way that she was so in that sense
she was hardcore but we still wouldn't
call her a gamer and so this notion of
the real gamer protocol is just there
are five rules that must all exist to be
a real gamer that's him
if you don't have every one of the
you're not a real game but then people
still game so what if you have two of
the three or four to five however you
want to put it like what am I then like
what's the classification that's where I
came up with you do have the casuals
then you do have like the hobbyist then
you have the enthusiast which a little
more serious than the obvious and then
you've got the real games like adding
that one game here's a real [ __ ] I
wanna I want to take addict points away
from knowledge like he's supposed to go
back to the joints your own Satan to the
gold in the real game is where you
comfortable classify you know he's busy
[Music]
there's too much backtracking give me
two Raiders throw in the bushes man I
got it though I mean
I tried to rock yeah I got mad love you
I got mad respect for your gaming
pedigree everybody gather right today
opinion then everybody's not gonna like
everything that is their goal that is to
lost your mind I want you to understand
I played all of the god of War's
beautiful beginning the end down left
and right when they went to this
perspective okay that's good for Gears
of War okay it's nice that you know you
went this way when I get to hold that
over my rules to the real game protocol
yes and really quick so now you can just
look at this list and read it you got to
make sure that you get the mantra that
goes with it and the list goes or the
mantra is while there is value when the
things on the right we value the things
on the left more so you're not choosing
one thing over the other you just said I
understand there's value in this thing
but I have more value in the three other
ones so the five rules is you prefer
gameplay over graphics and what that
means is we understand that there is
value in graphics but we prefer gameplay
more well that's the first one gameplay
over graphics okay the second one - do
you prefer
city over lack of variety so like my son
any first-person shooter to come out he
all over it but if you try to get him
the plate like stubble night he's like
oh that's trash like he only plays one
type of game and anything else he
considers it's not a game or real game
there's multiple types of games you
might not like everything but you're
gonna have more than one or two genres
that you play talk - genre check bins
but a third rule - the real game of
protocol is you prefer incredible gaming
experiences over a platformer loyalty
switch I don't care if it's on Xbox
Playstation PD it doesn't matter where
the games are is where I am doing the
Lord's work right now and then in the
fourth rule - the real gamer protocol is
real gamers preferred to form their own
opinions over listening to the viewer
again of review scores and that's not to
say that again it's not to say that
there is no value in those things
because there is this gentleman real
gamer will put more value in getting my
own opinions there are plenty of games
thank you the people have said that I
shouldn't like and I love their games
the people said that I should love
preaching the Lord's work right now cuz
you're gonna love you're gonna love the
poll catch it at the end of the show
because you won the same wait that's
crazy right there that you said that
continue and then the last one is quite
simply and it's really one of the most
important ones and again that's why
addict is on his list cuz he got off for
him and he really has this laugh you
don't got the other one oh geez
do this to you but let's let's compare
achievements let's go yo you going on
you know okay also let me tell you
something before you do that before you
do that I want the hacks Cognito this
question what was my game what was my
game name before that it was melon
Buster 1 right yes that is true I want
you to listen to this
my old pal was melon Buster won on that
account I have 500 360 games
I couldn't bring over those achievements
so hard on fighting for because my email
accounts for the lords in the real game
protocol is quite simply real gamers
prefer the game and skills game
yeah that's pretty much it now again
that's not to say that you won't ever
use a guide I think it's rare that you
would ever use the cheat code but if it
was rare so you may use a guy but it's
not to say that we don't use guys we
just say there's more value in gaming
skills over gaming guides so that's
that's pretty much all you have to say
about that King because this is what I
try to tell you a long time ago
because I hear y'all say it a lot in the
chat um Joe go look at YouTube so you
have to see how to do this or I heard
that this guy said that game was wack so
I don't know I've told you plenty of
times I live my life through me I don't
live my life that's why I can't sit
there and watch you play again because I
don't care about what you're
experiencing that's the part you don't
get into your head that's what I don't
understand
a twitch cuz I can't watch another man
play a game I will go buy the game I
will experience it myself I won't go to
youtube to figure out how to do
something that somebody else you down on
his own it's a different generation is
it let me jump in right cuz I think I
might have caused some confusion again
we won't use game guys and it's just
saying that we prefer like a few weeks
ago y'all had Eric's on and he really
helped me with the division he had to
like do a deep dive into like the new
weapon sets and all the gear okay I see
what you talkin about
now I would take that there was a
building block and go through the rest
myself
right but there's only so many hours in
a day so there's nothing wrong with you
know supplementing or using different
things to build your own knowledge what
I mean is you're not gonna go look I
can't beat this boss let me go see how
that generally this generation has they
they actually have more accent things
defense they have more access to that
whereas within
and our generation it was kind of like
you had to either wait for the strategy
guide for that to be really you had to
eat from solve no like you had to call I
thank God I was born later remember this
it was even like literally modification
devices aka you know said that would
allow you to do these cheap things and
infinite lives and all those other stuff
so it's just different errors you know
there but it is it there is a star come
on you know contrast to what's going on
we go I want to emphasize that don't
mean we don't do it if there is no value
in it it just means we value to other
things more because I mean truth being
told like I'm playing Ori and the blind
forest right now one thing to watch
somebody get to a level but that don't
mean you can do it just because you seen
them do it still gonna take you people
uh they can watch me fight feed the
orphan on a blood-borne don't mean they
don't beat themselves prestige range
we're not gonna go into that a
long-lasting boy you got everybody all
fired up today's this one
all right so 40 yo we gotta get you to
the hard part we challenge every game
you know guess with this you know I need
Lord code top five games or franchises
of all time your opinion let's go let me
let me say something first I need to put
a little caveat in here her I'm gonna be
I don't like misinformation and
misleading people so let me be very
clear no no dude everybody who does
anybody know who Jackie Owens is what
Jackie Owens was yes he was attractive
black track player oh yeah
where he was a track runner an Olympian
back in the olden days and what he did
was he won the Olympics for the United
States and he stood up there and he puts
a little black glove right yes oh yes
yes and everything that that was
important it was vitally important
because the world was fresh off of World
War two in the enjoyment there with this
whole master race thing yes and it was
expected that the Germans just because
they're purebred German race could beat
the world at the sporting events and
when Jackie joins be heard I'm at now
yeah when he meet that German he changed
the narrative for the entire world and
he made opportunities and people started
viewing black people and minorities very
differently than they had before because
you had to accept and not only can they
be equal they can be superior and that
was a big thing in a time that he lived
in yeah it was iconic it was an iconic
pose absolutely so now if you look at
track and field runners today I think
it's time I don't remember his time
Google knows but whatever his time was
the worst track and field runner today
will destroy the time that he had
they will all have better records than
him
as far as running the race that he ran
and doing it in a shorter amount of time
check the chat say Jesse Owens yeah
that's what I'm looking at and so while
today's track and field runners can be
better than him they will never be
greater than him his greatness set the
standard and it changed the world so
even though they will have better times
they will never have the same impact
well they got better drugs for that is
is there are plenty of games that are
out right now that are better than some
of the games that I'm about to list a
will never be greater than because those
games change the world in the industry
itself yes that's what I'm in charge of
the next guess I'm making sure that is
at least 25 and this guess is actually
giving you more props any guess that
we've ever had 5 greatest franchises are
greatest franchises iconic number 5 will
be I'm just going to go ahead and say EA
Sports Oh blew me like that first man
like you asked me to
the first NBA Lila really that Larry
Bird Oh George like magic worth the bird
in the NBA play now you're talking about
sports - es in era with the yellow tab
yay sports that whole thing I think of
they basically especially from my hood
bay nice so I had a background that was
say more street like a lot of things
that I did in my day life didn't match
the things in my nightlife little weird
mix that whole EA Sports sort of made
all of this other stuff not look so
nerdy anymore like what's that so EA
Sports definitely I think number five
yes
number four I will probably have to give
it to imma go ahead and say Street
Fighter but when I say Street Fighter I
mean that's the whole category of
fighting game in the arcade two-player
all general theme killer instinct that
whole thing that was started because of
that yes sir she fighters digit yeah
just attend number three will probably
have to be Ocarina you know there's
always one everyone's less yes yeah
number two and I really is I kind of
want to put this one that number one but
I can't but number two would probably be
the last of us because it did so much as
well but the number one and it's really
because of how we changed gaming
completely like gaming so they'll
remember that show called lost they used
to come on yes absolutely okay so I was
talking to a couple of guys that was way
younger than me and we were talking
about lost and they they were gonna
watch it on Netflix and I was trying to
let them know that the thing about you
watching lost in me watching lost when
it first came out is that you will not
have the perspective of being able to
see the world before it and seeing them
grow after it so you not be able to
appreciate how it changed the world
because you're already living in the
world that benefited from everything
that Lonnie did for TV and movies and
media preached and so the same thing is
true with this next game that I'm about
to say the number one the greatest game
in my opinion is called that changed the
world was clad to be Super Mario 64
because it is the one that showed you
how to take everything that we used to
do in 2d and how does this all of that
in 3d and still make it as fun and
accessible at the world in 2d once they
showed that blueprint to all the
developers everybody took off running
again with my friends who can beat it
quicker that changed the game cold like
you you're killing it right now you
people don't realize how impactful that
was because you just nailed it like it
it was the transition to the 3d space
and it was shown that it can be done and
I just remember the sensitivity of the
analog on the 64 controller and rotating
Mario in a 360 degrees space yeah and
just and then remember you would lightly
touch it he would he would kind of go
slower yeah yeah yes the precision yeah
you want to get technical the games that
are that were made from Nintendo from
that game like Mario Galaxy almost every
game that they've they was aware I'm
looking for it's been like pretty much
is like successor have scored above a
nine on that
critic that's the blueprint I gotta give
code dad he nailed it Matt Wow it said
I'll just have you know fantastic
history look oh wow I just keep talking
for hours like you've got it locked bad
we gotta get into the show but all I
want to talk about last week's poll the
results are in people have spoken to the
question with the recently confirmed
Xbox all access financing plan including
the console Xbox Live and game pass
announced by Microsoft do you think this
can negatively affect gamers the winner
at 51% in a fairly convincing three-way
ILP poll is the no this is a consumer
friendly option group coming in at
second and 25% where the shallows with
out of here where my exclusive games
that a razor close third place with 24%
of the vote was the yes disk targets
young gamers and creates debt group who
participated in the poll
Laura Cole what do you think about Xbox
all access no Dell what does anyone on
the panel think about Xbox all access no
it's guy apparently it's already
starting to be beneficial so so we got
that we got a new poll cooking up on the
IOP twitter stay tuned for the end of
the show let's get into these topics be
allowed to talk about so um i want to
shout out actually a tech affiliate brat
podcast and of course i want to shout
out our WCC tech actually for this
breaking news we're about to get into so
uh read that protection is in the news
apparently there was a 20-18 there was a
GME conference for those who don't know
to g-m-e
calling like GameStop's little
conference with a Gamestop crew goes out
there so on one of the publishers you
know they went out there and they got a
chance to um I'm gonna publish it for
read there they went out there they had
a demo
obviously we've seen though what is it
the kind of like five to six minute demo
of read their Redemption the trailer was
well-received but apparently these guys
at this gamestyle convention they got a
twenty minute demo so um basically one
of the users out there you know pretty
much one of them said you know very
positive
rest assured this will be the greatest
game ever made however there was a lot
of mixed reviews after saw you know the
showing so I'm gonna give you some
comments that was said from the people
who were in attendance all right one of
the users extended gameplay of what's
already been shown almost put me to
sleep
game looks good but they chose the show
the first twenty minutes was very boring
and not what you want to show people to
get hyped about your game another user
you might as well have put lullaby music
into that trip trailer to accompany the
narration I fell asleep a few times
during the demo I was hoping he could he
could shoot didn't torture the nuts and
so I was kind of like like ridiculous
when people say I fall asleep playing
the game razón then they were watching
this demo as opposed to playing one
other user this look like rockstar
equestrian simulator to k-19 was boring
as bleep
it was very anti-climatic oh I have a
big surprise for you and then a Red Dead
splash screen commenced I commenced
yawning he said it's not watch stuff
started happening it was a little better
but the presentation did nothing for me
another guy said beautiful game but
mostly what I saw was a horse riding
simulator you know I'm saying um people
I fell asleep
fell asleep fell asleep am i hurting off
to the city so yeah a lot of people I
can go on with that and then obviously
it wasn't all the people you know some
people say look you know they gotta take
it into context you know it was like a
like long day you know this was the last
demo of the day and maybe some people
were fatigued you know and maybe it
wasn't the best damn on show but um you
know some people said hey you know it
looked good there was a shootout after a
bank heist he saw 14 minutes of me and
rings rockstar playing but he said the
shootout looked different the bank
was pasted us phones just slowly paced
but it sold the demo and he was so so
based on this information and what we
Fredo I wanna start off with no it's all
rusted Lords have read their Redemption
frauds here and he is the true red dead
redemption guy Lord on the panel so
Louis file with these reports coming now
does this concern you in any way nah not
even a little bit listen the thing about
red dead what they've talked about what
they were all just are gonna drink that
kool-aid he's like fine that's fun world
Garen is attempting to do interaction
and immersion like no other game before
it like there's gonna be boring stuff
look it should move right we just got
sent move back right and what you
remember about Shenmue is that the
day-to-day stuff that you do that we
thought is cool which is cool the fact
that you can do menial tasks that stuff
is boring like into heart it's hard to
gamify that stuff so yeah I do I agree
that it was probably not the best idea
to give them a demo of how the horses
you know nuts way less whatever no yeah
it's probably not the best thing to do
that's that isn't something that they're
forcing you to interact with in that
good but DTA is different see the thing
about red as a no but as opposed to GTA
GTA is open world is more over the top
it's always been Red Dead is more
grounded it you know regardless of what
you if you like western stuff or not the
world is more grounded it's not GTA GTA
is very overtly action-oriented where
this is one of those like some of my
best moments in Red Dead Redemption and
this is not everybody right everybody
and some people like to play games like
action games for me some of my favorite
moments in Resident was just chilling
out in the desert like looking at the
sunset and being like wow they did this
like then me that was like wow I can't
believe they're doing this in the game
and the same goes for this they're just
trying to expand upon it it's not for
everybody and so yeah you need to show a
demo that's going to show the
five aspects of the game that people
gonna get excited about not everyone get
excited about how the horse moves how
realistic sound like these people
defended spider-man right now and I
think it speaks volumes looking I don't
want to make generalizations about you
they're not what I would sources and I'm
making general I realized at a curiosity
where was this like a meeting or was the
Jimmy conference so basically when it
comes to the GM's I've never met a Gian
there wasn't a foreigner just like
gamestop employees right there they have
privy access to this conference that's
kind of like they're mini guess you want
to say like a URI where they get to see
a lot of the games behind the scene I
know but they these games well I know
sovereigns going with this because like
uh you go in a Gamestop and there's a
lot of them they don't even know what
they're talking it's not eat remotely
but what because of these conferences
the people that go to these conferences
at work at games thought they're
informed right those tend to be the
higher level the managers of a store
right those type of guys tend to be
there you know Sam again but I
understand itself I think I will let you
finish
I get that they're probably higher
informed gamers but at the same time I
think there's so far ingrained in that
game stop sort of they may drink in the
games not do so much that it doesn't I
don't know it just feels like again like
if you if you look at the negative
comments about this stuff is the name
they showed some a boring aspect of the
game right that they want to see
gameplay listen if I'm getting shown a
demo of a game there's only been showing
once yeah I want to see action like I
would write the same way but much like
it's an aspect of the game that you
don't have to interact with the day it's
not like game stock demanded that one
they were sent that by
by day or two so like that's tech tools
fall right absolutely I do not think it
was a great don't do that like put out a
video like they do Xbox promotion right
now that doesn't make any sense that
they would do that show the action part
so what people want to see no that's not
something that everybody's gonna be
attracted to it's just not me personally
like I mentioned with the real gamer
protocol I don't care what anybody says
a set of people that have just seen a 20
minute demo was like wait you just
watched it you have the right to your
opinion but there's nothing that they
can say based on watching a 22 that will
make me lose or gain interest in the
game at the end of the day sovereign and
his code of read dead following they're
gonna buy this game that this game comes
out it's only 20 minutes long of a
cutscene they're still buying this game
so addict does this influence you in any
way cuz are you I don't take no you to
be a red dead guy but I just wanted like
no based on this does this influence you
any direction Red Dead being compared to
read dead - it's gonna be a good game
but people are trying to compare this to
GTA 5 like he's gonna do better that's
not it
and I'm just like look like GTA 5 is
phenomenal it's probably never gonna
happen again
it may be a better game in terms of the
tech and what they're trying to do in
the world and it may be a more immersive
game I don't think it I think it's gonna
be a more read their trailer was so
boring people out here talk about the
horse about physics at the end of the
day I think right that's still gonna be
good I think it's uh I still think I
don't know when it comes to like Game of
the Year like if this would have came
out in a different year I feel like it
would have been like automatic Game of
the Year but I feel like when you have
games like you know God of War out I
don't know if it's gonna be able to take
it from that that's like the only game
because red day is gonna get a lot of
clout just because red day
not exist I want to shout out Lord in me
I am saying it's atlona me I just let
people speak yeah he said Real Talk you
know he was against and he worked on
Gangstar for a month
he said the store manager wasn't even a
gamer he said we could get people coming
back mad about his suggestions because
he didn't know anything I'm sure there
is a lot of cases where you know they
they do exporting and hire people from
outside the company because it's easier
to run a store don't necessarily need to
know anything I'm sure the people that
run grocery stores have no clue thank
you don't go in there looking for a
pertinent information video game all I
know is like you know spend a lot of
game stops and for the most part like
when it comes to the management a lot of
them are more informed about games than
anyone else in that games thought like
sure they got certain employees they
especially around the you know the
seasonal hiring almost none of them
people know what they talk like this is
the hiring date for that rush you
sometimes it's a questionable characters
telling you what to get and stuff during
that time so you say I want though all
games up it is what it is if anything
that that's not game stalls fault that's
take two for giving a bad example of
their game I mean it's the first time
people got hands-on with their game
there's no excuse for that this is this
is Rockstar we're talking about and take
two you mean to tell me they didn't
think that was a good idea I just think
you know at the same time I I say this
look these guys have been working in
this game for like can you damn near ten
years it's like you know what let them
show off what they want to show off
that's to say let them be proud of
whatever aspect of the game
they're super proud of like again maybe
not the right audience for it maybe
you'd rather have like Game Journalists
in there and show them that sort of
stuff and they react differently to it I
prefer no gang journalist II that's kind
of crazy cake daddy I'm not gonna sit
here
oh you said - I'll be clear so well yeah
big man I need to go on this man let me
see just all right for the same reasons
that they said that they didn't like the
demo all right now remember again this
is a demo so they wanted to show you the
braid the blades of grass swaying I'm
pretty sure they wanted to show you the
fire physics they wanted to show you
they a interact horseback riding
simulator yeah listen I understand the
whole thing but the main objective to
the game most of times from travelling
points at point A to point B you're
gonna be on a horse you know so of
course you want the horse physics to
look right
did we play last guardian or whatever
that game was what was that that he was
on a horse for the PlayStation realms
right but but if you went from the first
time that they did the horse to the
remake everybody was talking about the
hare physics how he moved how he swayed
from left to right these guys from what
I've seen and this is the first time
that I've seen this actually put
scrotums
for a horse in the game okay so I don't
know how many games that did that and
this is just giving you a telling sign
of the game if you went down to that my
neat detail to show that this game is
going to be phenomenal because they're
going to tell you that every part of the
game is going to get that same attention
of detail so if you want that type of
game if that game is calling to you you
can go no further
it is gonna be the greatest game for you
for me it's not for me
like I wanna speak real quick to what
King just said because at a higher level
of abstraction for me it's the pedigree
that Rockstar
like they automatically get an instant
pass from me like okay they've done too
much right for me to think that they
just don't mess up
epic and then the next thing that that
is really attracted me to the title is
because of their gaming pedigree and
this is their first true next-gen title
I don't see them messing that up and all
like GTA was previous generation look
this is the actual first next title from
rocks at the end of the day there's more
red dead cult members out there than
there is certain populations in the
country you know it might adjust cells
by like a couple but what what code is
saying what code is saying is true every
Rockstar release is an event and it's an
event because they make it that way they
make it that way because they make sure
they're not like they're not like an
anchors gonna kill me and then Esther
they're not Bethesda that goes into a
hole and comes back out you know six
years later with a game that's just
similar to the last one they just they
loved fallout 4 but it was far less was
trash will get it will get into that
with the cyber bug topic but um you know
they come out and you know they're gonna
they're pushing the tech forward they're
pushing AI forward pushing interactivity
in the world for you know you're gonna
see things that you haven't really seen
before at least them you know they're
gonna attempt it regardless whether they
fail or not wrong and that's what's
exciting for me about any rockstar
release like any rockstar release so
listen it's me I feel you sell right
when it late I'll finish this thing off
um yeah man listen I mean when I first
I'm not gonna fry what I was died laughs
I had a class I was like this was funny
I know this is sobs hearts
I don't redo a whole thumbnail for this
I thought it was I hit up cold late last
night to us it's the last minute
addition where we got
we gotta talk about at the roundtable
but in context it's a 20 it's an
extended version of that six minute
thing it's one mission I'm not gonna go
crazy I thought it was funny you know
there but you know also to give context
also for the people who did it with many
positive people so it was it wasn't like
all bad like there were people that said
look man I thought it was a game of the
year intent that gave me a contender
there people said you know that listen
this is the people who were speaking
negative but a vocal minority this is a
guy that was there he says the murmurs
and talk of how amazing it looks far
outweigh the few people who are voicing
negative opinions they showed off
graphics robbery they said it looks
gorgeous the physics were amazing
they said it's easily going to compete
with God of War and he said I also see
spider-man 2 Kings happiness making the
list as well and that was shout the
black static for me I believe used
already actually said so listen at the
end of the day if you love red dead
you're gonna continue to love rent dead
I agree with all cold you know their
pedigree is enough to say listen I ain't
gonna get too crazy about this
like let's wait for fun and relieve this
way as things get closer more
information comes out but that's all I
have on this topic we're going to move
on Lord saw cyber Punk business what's
going on yeah so this past week we
finally got the gameplay revealed that
everybody had seen that some people had
seen at a at e3 and at Gamescom
everybody got to finally see it um I
just want to know what you guys thought
about it did you were you overwhelmed
underwhelmed was it exactly what you
expected and beyond that if you thought
it was next level if it was something
really special do you think that
although art Western RPG developers have
something to worry about with them this
bit says they have to look at what
they're doing be like you know what
we've got to step up our game
there's obsidian need to step up their
game does you know EA and Bioware D to
step up their game and what do they need
no doubt alright so Attica in Japan yeah
I wasn't on the cyberpunk stuff you know
they made one game and people acting
like they the God's gift to gay
but but after that gameplay man I'm
officially on the hype track I 1477
right now so it is what it is that like
they they took first off I'm a huge fan
of DX X and that is like how the game
should have been yeah you saw you know
obviously the game's not gonna look like
that on launch with consoles probably
that's probably more of a PC build but I
guarantee we won't get much less mm-hmm
but you know from what they were doing
they you know they were having to where
you could capture people in like splice
into they network and deactivate
everything if you like that's what I'm a
ballast gun person it seems like that
game is like they're going to like I
always felt like stealth games that try
to make a you know two approaches you
can do stealthy you could do just
straight-up going in there guns blazing
almost felt like most of them always had
the guns blazing high later than the
stealth it's just heard you to be
stealthy yes this game feels like they
have both on both sides equal like you
can either take which one and you won't
be affected by you all right and I want
to ask this because Cassidy but actually
stealing to my point that I was gonna
mention when it got to me but I mention
it to y'all he basically said cuz
there's a lot
I've never played the first one so I
wanted to a lot of people are mad from
what I understand that it's not it's
doing the first-person so you know shot
the cat he was like yeah motor sickness
he don't he's gonna be disappointed like
does you guys that have played it you
know the original like does this
transition to third-person I mean you
know the first person body original this
is the first one cyberpunk
and the first Punk was actually a pen
and paper we're talking about The
Witcher yeah I mean I guess the
comparison was The Witcher right I guess
a lot of people expected this game to be
third persons as to which would drive
their their reasoning for doing a
first-person as they wanted to create a
like a higher level of immersion by
having you see through the eyes of the
protagonist so I understand that and I
think that is I think it's true in that
respect they want you to feel like
you're ingrained in this world
differently than with The Witcher
because with The Witcher
um it's your Geralt right so you're
living through Geralt its Geralt story
here you argue ate your character you're
amazing your character there is certain
archetypes but it is you so I understand
that first-person perspective in terms
of like an oak add a dimension like
motion sickness I know they have motion
blur things in effect where it limits
that for people I hope they do something
to kind of stay that off but no he can
take a pill and like you know like once
the people they didn't like first person
that played The Witcher I mean third
person that played The Witcher I mean
you keep if you don't want to play this
game because the first person guess what
cat daddy don't play it a lot of people
that don't want to play this game
because his first personally I get it
this whole generation third person has
dominated maybe we need that push that
someone like a competent developer like
you know this project read making a
first-person to push the whole genre but
they actually it's an interesting
subject because they spoke to um CD
Projekt RED about this and they said he
they are aware that many fans
they're not fans of it being in the
first-person perspective but he kind of
he stood on his square and he was just
like he feels just a small number of
people you know I was who can't play for
a variety reason but he's doubling down
and saying that look man they're gonna
continue to leave it this way you don't
say they're not going in so literally
that I mean they just had that
conversation
um I'll jump in man like I got a chance
to finally it's 48 out you know 48 48
minute demo calm looked amazing I mean
this thing regardless like whatever this
thing turns out to be this is built for
me you got sci-fi got cybernetic the
future don't switch it switch a block so
not me Laura cordon and thing I got me
loss off is the city's like
just density right cuz you had all the
people to me you know what it is King it
felt like from the way they did the city
felt like the evolution of Shenmue like
they had people I mean it's a mashup
just like just like Optimus Co said this
games that came before this they left
the blueprint right but I'm pretty sure
all these people that's old tripping all
over this building losing in mind they
probably didn't play fallout they
probably put them played their sex which
is a phenomenal game I mean that game is
already in the store it's already there
i watch I'm not gonna do two hours I'm
to hell with that I'm not doing that but
i sat there and i watch probably 15 20
minutes of it got a gist of it and I'm
gonna buy the game you're gonna beat the
game that's the question is from a
day-to-day basis and I love the fact
that you're concerned with what I be but
at the same time if I beat it I'll send
you a memo just make sure that you're
able to get the game to play the game
def legal rock do these things oh my god
referencing [ __ ] will get Bush's respect
on shamu names yeah you don't have to I
give you I wouldn't be seeing all this
level of City interactivity that's cool
we should've stayed password you
wouldn't have it if it wasn't
the past bushes come in the future
history but like I always say you know
I'm very excited about it man this thing
it realistic to me I cannot hear you
I'm not saying it's doing something
never been done before I'm not saying
that what I'm saying is there's certain
games that come along and breath of the
wild is one of them where I consider it
a marriage of all these great systems
you know I'm saying from other games
that just make this game really though
it takes the company doing features that
another company did I mean there's no
loading and the thing that got me is and
we're gonna get into that on the next
topic when I talk about anthem is they
got the dialogue choices that affect how
the game goals flow the princes are the
one thing you know I mean so I'm in
continue at it the one thing I want to
point out is you know a lot of these
first-person besides today xx like the
main character who doesn't have a voice
right and like this should like
obviously I like the chick version like
you like it made it seem like they put a
lot of time in dialogue and if you can
make this that you can make the worst
game average if it has a good dialogue
and the witcher if you look at the
witcher and its entity like a lot of
things new but it did it correctly yes
two cups of jack really stop it [ __ ]
would rise influence every game every
influence shimu facts to shadow Santo
but this is what I'm saying
he said it's doing something top-tier in
every way possible that in it of itself
makes it something that's a level oh
it's a level of polish and that type of
game they're going for a level of Polish
that you do we see in the game I do for
me what makes it most exciting because
when I first you know you heard all the
stuff coming out of e3 people like oh my
god it's the greatest thing I ever saw
and when I saw it when I actually saw it
running I was
little underwhelmed because I was I
looked at I'm like it's a game I'm like
it's a game it's not this bad bye yes
not to cut you loose like yourself
that's why I said King please I was with
you King I was first 15 minutes that's
the point
listen I'm not gonna tell you I'm not
gonna do that
that's not gonna happen but what is
gonna happen I'm gonna play the game I
saw enough of the game to justify
people's excitement you know like oh my
god this is it and they're going to take
every criticism from those other games
that I talked about their sex and um
fall out and they're gonna sharpen this
steel they're gonna polish it they're
gonna get it nice and they're gonna push
it out the door for you so yes you're
gonna because of those games that came
before it they're gonna give you a top
tier game what I'm trying to say is take
your behind don't wait for the game to
come out in 20 whatever the hell go out
and buy those other games this is
probably on sale right now and get a
feel of these games so you know exactly
what you're gonna be playing where it
comes from
yeah and I think I think the most
important thing for this game and where
its next level where the tempting could
be next level in that world immersion
and that AI I think when you talk about
cyberpunk you talk about being like
linked and can't really comment on the
world immersion because like we haven't
seen it enough to really call I haven't
seen but that's what they're going for
like that's what that's the thing that
they're going for the Creator you want
to create a world that feels like it's
lived in right and to do that especially
with the topic like cyberpunk a
cyberpunk is so reliant on like future
tech Androids being jacked into
everything of there you create a world
where all those rules actually apply to
the gameplay
adapt the seed in the cherry with the up
grow although I gotta say this right
they didn't show a boring whack the
horse
so we can't we can't say we go urgent
getting announced with Mario cyber did
you get a chance to see the cyberpunk
demo absolutely I work with the amount
of technical prowess that I've seen in
the game all the different subsystems
that they have interacting together I am
very impressed with the game not
bitching graphically I like the theme
the sci-fi theme like everybody said
deus ex was like phenomenal and it's
it's a shame that people don't really
understand how dope that game is but
yeah I do think that this is taking it
to the next level
absolutely I'm very excited like but I
was more impressed with the gameplay
mechanics I want to actually question
because being at you a coder and you
just said it you saw all the subsystems
you get excited from different
perspective opposed to us like we get
excited from graphics oh what eat do X
and it came back we excited over that
you get excited off of seeing all the
intact and the level of code and how
hard it must have been to bring that
game to fruition so this is what I'm
saying like when you saw that game
because everybody was talking about it
was doing all this crazy stuff but from
your eyes from from your tape and you
saw this different subsystems and stuff
like that what did you feel from it from
a technical standpoint Oh
felt like they were top-notch like this
is a lot of subsystems working together
and working together extremely well like
the potential for bugs and things that
go wrong with all of the things that
they had working together like jacking
into people disabling they comms and
taking over this thing and like we can
go through here and just like all of
that could go horribly wrong
sorely but they did a really good job
and I've just seen all the technical
excellence
in addition to the graphical display
because I thought the graphics was
top-notch too but just all of the code
that has to be working and I literally
thought I wonder how many million lines
of code do they have to make this work
absolutely shut up from frogs you've got
to relax for Planet X everybody Western
developers RPG developers got to be on
notice man like Oh baby like not fallout
76 because that's a different thing but
the next fall out and the next Elder
Scrolls and these guys are playing in
there and won't Park now right because
regardless of the perspective shift like
worst person creating a game first
person is very different to doing it in
third person absolutely if you look at
the third person you know option and in
fallout I was not the guys he walks in
like a stick figure it's not really
meant for that you know I mean so it's
interesting that these guys are playing
in somebody else's backyard and it's
gonna be interesting to see how they
elevate that and if these guys need to
look at this and change up what they're
doing and I know that goes into like the
battlenet into my stomach and I'm glad
you said that everybody else need to be
on notice because these guys are going
for going for the go titles they really
are
CD Projekt I don't think they'll get the
go title well I think it's gonna be a
phenomenal game but I don't think it's
gonna be like that let's see we got time
apparently I don't think it's you know
I'll put it this way I don't think it's
gonna
pass Witcher 3 look you know what's
crazy about that statement though it's
the same people right
that'sthat's digis shows how the
excellence that's coming from CD Projekt
RED shot the santoses guys I think this
is gonna be a solid eight five nine game
but I don't think it's gonna surpass
which here because Witcher it was third
person and that appeals to more people
in the long run if you but this okay
this question would it surpass which are
one or two you know because they
actually built a following all the way
up to get you to three comparing a
jumping-off point to an established
that's a good love character but was not
the wave like that regardless what a
developer works on you I think you
should always compare their last word to
their new word because you can't really
compare which this is any indication
excellence they're showing I think I
think it's fair to say something like
that comparing it like on the same level
because this is something new for them
they've never made a first-person game I
don't think so like they're doing it
better than the people who make
first-timers and that's the thing that's
and that's the thing to me the
first-person games appeal so a lot of
people like you people buy a Call of
Duty every single year like if they can
give you a game what I'm sorry going at
it their balances all that stuff and
does it all right like you can do the
stealth you can do the shooting you can
do all the other RPG stuff and you could
do it as well as anybody else has ever
done it before I don't see how that
doesn't surpass the which I feel like
first person is is really popular but
it's cuz of a multiplayer aspect I don't
feel like it's a single-player aspect
there are games that that's the
exception right but this isn't Bethesda
and for the most part they've always
dominated that RPG first person they
love you but if you look at Bethesda
games they give you a third person off
- so you can get right into that daddy
this is yes we do shift to 11:00 a.m.
when football season we already have the
intro and everything pop and everybody
will have all that information coming up
this week so yes we all may be used to
this and that he doesn't want to change
I shall be moving along great side of
our topic topic any perfect transition
start to mind because um yeah it was a
dialogue choice was something that was
very big to me but let's talk about you
a real quick and um yes it's about
interesting things going on right now
obviously you know we've heard about the
battlefield 5 delay it's going out of
October into November and um you know as
a result there's also been you know a
big bonus a big drop but a 10% stop drop
on EA so there's gonna be a two-part
thing so the first part is gonna be
about battlefield 5 was that right
decision
EA and then the second part is this one
is near and dear to me you know it's
gonna be a little rant from Laura
kognito
um so pretty much anthem obviously is
the most you know anticipated thing from
the you know from EA coming up next year
it's a big title we got a boys Bioware
KC [ __ ] in the crew and some news just
came out and pretty much I believe one
of the executive producers mark Dora he
put out that um it was found out that
Bioware games IV no Mass Effect if you
guys play Dragon Age Allah stuff these
are multi dialogue choice games that
affect the gameplay so similar to what
cyberpunk is setting out to do right
that's what Bioware is known for so
pretty much it was just found out that
in their systems and in anthem they only
gonna allow for two dialogue options so
they asked him about
he said mark Darcy we're showing the
audience we're showing it to an audience
that is not used to these kinds of
decisions and conversations we wanted to
keep it simpler but we also didn't want
to want to print it presents you with
false choices so for Tarsus is going to
be this areas like a single player area
with that's gonna happen you know where
my heart is with heard these statements
so you know for Tarsus apparently is
this you know area where you're gonna be
in the first person you know it's
perspective as opposed to the third
person perspective with the javelins in
the shared world so that's gonna this is
where that's gonna happen the single
player thing and he just you know it's
clearly not gonna be just another
Bioware RPG so I want to bring this to
the Lord's you know part one battlefield
5 is that the right decision part to
anthem dialogue choices and quote
unquote simplification of dialogue so
let's start with Lord code what do you
think about both of these things have an
opinion
I don't so I look at a lot of the I
guess you would call it the gaming
community and especially a lot of the
news from the chrome side let's just say
let me see how can I put this so I'm not
affiliated with Sony in any way okay I'm
not affiliated with Microsoft in any way
I'm not affiliated with Nintendo in any
way zero form or fashion okay
but I do write socks or billion-dollar
organizations and a lot of that I write
a lot of y'all probably used every day
but like our company cuz we were
consultants so we don't put our name on
it people hire us to write software for
their backs
so I write software for a lot of people
a lot of big-name people and I'm often
have to meet with the Klein
mm-hm and one thing that I will say for
sure when I look at this gaming
community is none of you people could
ever run a successful gaming business
the ideas that you have and like this is
what they should do and win and this is
a good idea bad idea all you lookin at
is like what you like and what your
personal preferences are and none of
those are valid for running a business
oh that's rich ultimate billion-dollar
business so one thing I hate having
lived let's say a hard life or a let's
just say somewhat shady background
I hate when I'm watching TV and it's
some criminal or some heist going on
that I'm watching TV with try to say all
they have to do to get away you don't
like the all you got to do Lord you
don't like that criminal like you don't
know what you would do you don't know
what it takes to be a criminal on your
little suggestions or from you out here
on the couch your your opinion has no
weight anyway that means backseat
driving the gaming advice that these
game players try to give these companies
is like laughable is like why would they
ever listen to you wonder then the mind
share that they won't you know for
public perception and as far as making
business moves and business deals like
people laugh at Microsoft's that ain't
losing this generation or whatever like
do you understand business and how it
works
stop eating that I've been in with these
clients in these organizations and we
would embarrass ourselves trying to give
these people business advice I'm saying
all that to say this if EA has
determined that the release window for
battlefield needs to be something
different than what it is I guarantee
you a lot of research has gone into that
and they have deemed it is in our best
business interest to move this and for
no other reason and I don't have access
to that information so I can't
second-guess it
if they have decided this is what they
mean to do then yeah I'm pretty sure
that that's what they need to do a lot
of code - I apologize but I did go in
now as far as get response and then I
get it pretty bad to go I've always said
from the from day one you guys have
always said like you know it's it's
harder to run a company than it is to
take opinions on a company but at the
end of the day EA has been doing a lot
of missteps here lately
right they messed up respawns game
because that game sold really really bad
even the the director of respawn they've
mentioned the cells and he's like yeah
no help from EA they caught they they
dropped the ball with a battlefield
because they had a develop come out
openly and tell the consumers that are
supposed to buy their game if you don't
like it just don't buy it
like they called them they called them
in What did he say they said like he
doesn't say that they were stupid but he
stated they're uninformed like they're
miss educated or sometimes because of
our female being on the cover of
battlefield and then you look at Bungie
like Bungie thought they had everything
all their eyes not at all their t's
crossed and then the Destiny to drop and
oh okay maybe we should have listened to
the community like what we see how it is
they perspective
you know stats they say okay these what
people want these world people want but
the problem with you know how the
industry works is it's constantly
evolving you can people forget that
these games are made from three to four
years at a time the way that they made
this game and that their visions three
years ago not necessarily is how the
industry is going today I mean that's
all true in this we can probably have
like a whole nother topic on this but
addict so what you said is certainly
true and it has wait but it's the
difference between hindsight and
foresight is greed that after something
to say but I
and if organizations could do that they
absolutely would make every move perfect
but all they can do is look at what's
available to them at the time and just
like in in in the NFL I don't know I
don't know if y'all outlaw NFL talk or
not but changing our time to 11:00 a.m.
next week popular topic before coaches
in the NFL that goes if you were NFL
head coach if you listen to the fans
you'll be sitting will like I didn't
listen to the fans sometimes what you
think is best for the game isn't best
for the game goes to the like sometimes
common sense supersedes business sense
right and in this sense when you when
you see what they did to titanfall to
write a view it's obvious that once once
the landscape of October started they
saw it they needed to move that game
right because it was sandwich and that's
just that's just the examples of that
look what they do mass effect hey these
days have been dropping balls more than
they've been picking them up yeah but
see the thing is everybody keeps saying
I don't know why they put out this
battlefield at the same time every year
around the same time with these same
games and they moved it when Microsoft
did it with crackdown and he moved it
listen hey they know I'm not gonna sell
here let me move my spots over here so I
can just get these off and let the
sellers over here but like where they if
they were about the sells I feel like it
would have been out of the year entirely
like did there still
[Laughter]
not much it's real members not met let
that go get it cuz we keep interrupting
cool conversation is great this and
again Atika I understand what you're
saying or stop I understand what you
saying but there's more that goes into
it than that is you can't just say I'm
going to go into next year
those are publicly traded companies they
have projections for a year right head
of shareholders they have to answer to
and they have to try to make things work
to match their projections and it's not
as easy as just saying okay we'll just
do it like six months from now and again
so like Lord King like I don't know if
you saw this or not but with Floyd
Mayweather was about the fight McGregor
and it was all this talk about Floyd
it's this guy right here he earns a shot
if you gonna leave the game if this your
last fight why not give one of these
thirsty young boxers a shot why not bite
this cat that cat like why would you
fight McGregor and he looked at the
camera and he said cuz it makes the most
business sense million dollars yeah and
so a lot of what they fix that's what
they use to make the decision now we're
not saying that they don't get it wrong
because they certainly do but given the
information that they have and they do
listen to the community we're not saying
zero percent is just right it is more
than the voice of the community
and so they will get it wrong but what
they're trying to do is maximize profits
whatever they think they can I think
that's I can't hit I say one more time
can you hear me
knocking yeah I think it was a PR stunt
I think they had so much bad publicity
they're trying to put a little distance
between that but it's only a month why
would it be a PR stunt it was out if you
look at the they did the comparisons to
call a duty that they're usually around
the same ballgame like the the pre-order
like 85% down than what they normally
are okay so what does that got to do
with a PR still read dead is is involved
in there somewhere
good games coming out this yeah I
honestly would have told them ship it to
next year to be honest with you because
you already put your money down on
pre-order people have been pre-ordering
these a year out now that it from next
year standpoint like it seems like next
year the first couple months are really
crazy too you can't you can't really
move that you though because you got
anthem you got division you got I don't
to say cuz check a laughs way down I
said like you got a bunch of things all
at Metro wheat that they're doing
marketing for crackdown right now they
should put out in December on the 24th
just like December are like like the
redheaded stepchild but to code point
like you have to admit like again we
don't know what's going on in these
ballrooms we don't know the financial
ramifications going on and you know for
me personally I applaud the move I think
it's a great move I think they have to
learn a little bit from the titanfall to
Fiasco my sandwich in between games cuz
that game was let you know how to die
and this is a fantastic game they
cannibalize their own game with
battlefield with that they did it to
themselves
exactly so get away from that you know
you get between Red Dead and Call of
Duty you get out November yeah fallout
it's fall out there's no doubt it's a
new genre a new thing for sex but I
think it's or okay you know I'm saying I
want to get now to a second just let me
say one day I find it you know makes a
better release date than the original
one just because they're getting away
from call of duty and right then it the
day I like I don't think it's gonna
drastically be different like we got to
see we got to see right so the second
the second part is that I went back to
loco again which was on the whole anthem
thing the dialogue choices being limited
to to them saying that their audience
you know they bring it to a new audience
that in the sense it's kind of they want
to simplify um
you know the whole choice thing how do
you feel about that and where did you
play a lot of the older you know um by
working like a Mass Effect like a
dragon's age of course the thing is that
I think that they are damage controlling
but I don't think is something that
necessarily needs to be damage control
because for me I don't know I don't know
who they're they're audiences or who
their target demographic is but for me
I'm only doing enough single clearing
anthem to beef my dude up for the
multiplayer when I'm running around with
y'all so so do you
there's an outcry of people that are
like hey and obstacle get into it cuz
let me get my ring my thing is good this
is me I'm not gonna say how great this
is me you know but there is you know I
haven't I feel a way about it only from
the standpoint is this is what Bioware
is known for this is their mo like when
we I got into Mass Effect I fell in love
with that game because of dialogue
choice and how it affects relationships
and character and you know development
as well as the ending of a game like
that the path of the game coaching so
when I see stuff like cyberpunk doing
the formula that Bioware created it by
we're not doing it in their own game and
just to Lord addicts point when I heard
that you know those comments it bothers
me you know because they saying new
audience and when I hear that I think of
destiny to and the horrible launch that
it had right and it's like you're taking
away from your own formula to now
quote-unquote brought in your parents
and I'm worried about that and then
we've already had the issue with okay
there's not gonna be any PvP on launch
right okay fine I'll let that rock I
seen the demo you know I'm saying we saw
also at EA airplay it looked it looked
good I'm not gonna say it didn't it look
really good I'm excited but I was
curious like how does the story go how
does the interaction and to now he is
like it's kind of like
a single-player separate area and it
doesn't again we don't know all the
information I don't know information I
could be very much wrong as more stuff
comes forward but for what we know right
now with this for Tarsus thing it just
seems like an isolated separate thing
that your character does and it really
doesn't feel to have any overarching
effect on the game and if that's the
case I'm gonna have a problem with this
real quick go for it I won't take but a
few side please please do please so
again I think that they are right there
so you're talking about we want to take
all the single-player mechanics and put
it in a multiplayer in like an MMO and
we want that to work seamlessly in just
a few weeks ago I heard y'all really
complaining about Monster Hunter if you
haven't I'm trying to power people and
I'm playing with my grandson and I'm
teaching him how to play but I got away
because he got to see this cutscene
first are these dialog choices and so
for me like even though Monster Hunter
was great and I really liked it
it demonstrated how when you try to
merge too many things that aren't a
natural fit it can just be a big
inconvenience and so for me I'm looking
at anthem as a MMO and a single-player
is just some little bonus thing that I
may or may not get to write but it seems
like you're looking at it more as the
single-player RPG that you after and
it's somehow been lessened because you
won't get that full experience and I got
you at it um here's the thing you are
correct it is a different style of game
right this is an MMO world shared
shooter I understand they may never
somebody's reverberant but I may
understand that like you know they may
not be able to seamlessly integrate Oh
Mass Effect style story in that type
okay I get that but I just from me it
hurts because I guess because Casey
Hudson is on it when I heard his name is
associated I'm like okay that's what
he's known for
right and then it's just like oh like it
was straight Andromeda I got that dirty
taste of a drama let me throw a dirtier
wrench into this whole conversation I
don't know if you guys saw this headline
on V T 24/7 it just came up they said
that future Mass Effect and Dragon Age
games will be heavily influenced by
anthem yeah wait you said future which
is my whole point which is that
direction
real quick because you know I've told
you before I've said it before this
Ironman simulator is going straight to
the bushes they're gonna fall beneath
Division one now the vision - they're
gonna fall beneath Division one as far
as the group of people that's gonna play
this game okay um and the reason why
they're chasing the casual dragon is
because the success of games like
fortnight the success of destiny even if
you say destiny - was a failure as a
failure compared to itself helps but
it's nice it's not a family finding it's
not a failure
okay they're chasing the casual dragon
now they understand that they can't give
you all these chains just like Optimus
coset they can't give you all these
things that don't fit hmm they hear the
talk they understand what it is and what
they're doing is they're lessening the
blow for you right now
mmm they're telling you right now before
you purchase a long time so you can be
like when you purchase it you plan to be
like yet it did say was only gonna be
like - two - that's a dialogue yeah
that's true - this
they are softening your skull for the
head crack right now all right
you fall for that head crack and and say
yo I'm gonna get this game I'm only
going to play the EA pass fun thing the
TA access yeah I'm going to play that
ten hours they give me and that game is
going directly into the bushes because
when they said no multiplayer they're
robbing you like a rocket this off um
yeah I wanna hit codes response no no no
just then they is multiplayer just no
good I wanna fight somebody might think
that that's fine I understand what cog
is coming from
I completely understand it because since
that's what Casey is known for by Adam
was their opportunity to take the
destiny formula and elevate it to
another level right they're not doing
that they're just adhering to what's
there already to try to make another
meet like an also-ran at that hopefully
it's hopefully it's just as good
hopefully it's it does something
different but by them eliminating that
aspect of Bioware's pedigree it feels
like it's a totally different thing now
that's fine if you don't like it for
anthem cool I understand that but it is
a new thing it's not necessarily you
can't necessarily expect that now it's
other thing though if you're telling me
that Mass Effect is gonna be affected by
this type of gameplay if they ragga nate
is gonna turn into this type of game I
just want you to notice and this is
what's happening because you keep saying
katie ussin
yeah gates yes and it's and silver
alright um this is you know where i'm
he's a name is a name it's a name you
can trust fights right now can you trust
this game
demanda show themself disrespect the
gray case yawns that's uh he dislike
them so I know where you're going right
I'm willing like more fast back in the
chat I am willing to reserve judgment
until release but also can I hear what
you're saying
I feel like head cracks baby oil you
know again it's just not the game it may
be amazing a good game it just may not
be the game for me based on my
assumptions coming in on what was a
simple that's all I'm saying it's just
one of those things that I'm like okay
and again when I hear terminology like
oh this is a different audience we're
simplifying it that's not use those
kinds of decisions and conversations
it just feels it doesn't feel right you
guys don't think if this game is
insanely successful that it's Dragon Age
then I think it will absolutely they
said as much no matter what success or
not this formula is being used in what
we consider to be proper RPGs Mass
Effect and Dragon Age that's this
heartening I don't care how you look at
it that's disheartening to me and I and
I realized that the mass effect formula
has gotten more more casual friendly
from the first one but still it's but
still like to me to make it this type of
game that's not what I want out of mass
and it still may be successful and it
still may follow the destiny for it may
be Fantan it's just a different game
that's all I'm saying and that's all I
got on my rant all I have to say is
anthon going the bushes Wow every time I
hear more about anything I'm like
literally like every time we've heard
something about
it's not like a cool trailer or anything
like that it's you know what's funny is
I show this cutscene and the same people
that are complaining about destiny story
are the same people hyping this stuff
and I'm just like look at this game oh
it's got a cool cutscene guess what
Destiny's got cool cutscenes that's the
part that killed me the same people that
are hyping up that story the story
trailer that just launched cuz I'm
what's the reaction to it but I was like
nah and that's not for me that they can
keep that
but as I'm seeing this story the same
people I'm seeing that's completely over
this game they're like oh it's gonna be
amazing it's gonna be the craziest thing
ever I say people that Kade expansion
that just came out that trailers way
better sure it's an established brand
that has inheritors that people know but
I'm saying you're looking at the same
way it's got story trailers too but for
some reason one's OK and the other ones
not I wanna shout out to lastly let's
come come oh he said everyone's so
heated over by where and their
franchises will want to keep their eyes
peeled next week Lord editor with the
exclusive so it's coming
we don't talk behind the scenes hey
child to protect perfectly yeah I feel
like they got the baby oil pretty
important and we talked about it in
passing
like we acknowledge it but we don't
really like talk about it talk about
when I say we I mean a game of community
there's a very big difference and there
is a stark difference between the
developer and the publisher right most
of the time the developer wants to give
the gamers what they want and a lot of
times the developers themselves are also
gamers and so they understand things
from the perspective of a gamer preach
the problem is that the publishers will
come in and the publishers primary
objective is to make money yes they
think that if the developer has a core
audience here like an RPG this is
actually happened in our game in history
in our name and if an RPG does really
good a man
it's core market but it captures the
attention of a bunch of casuals someone
in the business will say why we hit 10
million that's great we expected to hit
1 million but we had 10 million that's
great but why wasn't that 1024 why
wasn't that 20 30 and they will always
make changes and they don't mind risking
alienating their Court that's very true
it's so true
you'll appreciate or though the
developer tries to guard against that
but they only have so much power
yes point is we really in this
conversation we should differentiate
between Bioware and EA EA and that's why
work and get a different publisher like
Sony where they have more creative
freedom over their own products hmm they
may have a different conversation so
there doesn't be careful about blaming
the developer so like EA is taking it
studios and is running through the
bushes bad like it's like they take it's
like you know that that scene in 300
where that you just G kicks leonidas
kicks uh the messenger off that big hole
well it's like they do that and it's
like they looking down the hole like if
you could crawl up crawl up like it is
really gotta move oh we betta stated
that but fantastic words of wisdom the
chat is loving lord cold and like yo
uncle optimus preaching everybody saying
it and you're right i need to make that
separation between Bioware and EA
because again maybe Mike or Bioware
still has those things in place I would
like to but again it's the call of you
know I'm saying to publish X and just
like Bioware and they're just tagged
Laura Cognito on Twitter and Vegas this
year Bioware let's go to slide through
these last two we get out of it like
what's that man
what's going on with Xbox well Xbox
clearly ok for those of you I want to
make this quick because we're going with
but uh for those of you are destiny and
I destiny
at Gamescom they actually had an inside
Xbox they didn't really announce
anything you know relevant there they
did like you know the the hunt thing I
think that was pretty good you know we
obviously if you want to you can look at
last week we went pretty detailed I
think into but you know so we're not
really talking about inside Xbox for say
I'm talking about the announcements they
made afterwards they uh the e the all
access and they announced the white
elite controller yes yeah I kind of feel
like that should have been an inside
Xbox like I just don't understand where
are you gonna spend 15 minutes talking
about something that no one cares about
like assembling an arcade machine when
you had information that people went to
watch inside Xbox with they could have
broke it down a little bit more people
are still confused on all access when
they had like well it was like sixty
thousand people watching inside Xbox
that's where they should they could have
made this confusion more you know not
confused are you talking about the
controller I'm saying that those should
have been on a I know shade there
weren't targeted market they weren't all
access wasn't gonna target that market
so it didn't make sense but at the end
of the day okay maybe not to all access
but why was it the controller at least
there I don't know it doesn't make sense
because that was the platform yeah it I
just feel like you know the All Access
thing that's not at Gamescom forgot
about Jeremy yeah but you know that's
cool value of inside Xbox we know that's
in the bushes but what I'm saying is
they showed I don't know how many custom
fake custom systems that they show they
sold a show like what like four or five
of them right mm-hmm
yeah there's like four release
semi-custom no there was one that was
like a brown color no but I think to
that point that got left on the cutting
room floor I think they were saying that
the bundles was more important than
actually talking about that one
controller because I think the
controller could have been thrown in
there with the white system but then
again as I think they wanted to push
those announcing the new custom things
that's on the store and they were like
and you know what else brought you right
now or whenever they're gonna announce
it we're actually launching an elite
control like I just don't like why you
say nobody wants their old model though
it was a new version but at the same
time it's like you're gonna announce it
on Twitter like you're gonna let Major
Nelson announce it on his website it's
like but you built this platform to
announce that shadow JD Gary said Larry
they want to pull out the white gloves
on the white control again so um yeah
some some decisions are surprising some
of them I think are arm region based on
but some are surprising in that I was
surprised but let's just get to the
business like I ain't interested in next
controller I mean if it's not version to
elite my boy David preen that's my dude
that's the homie he's the originator of
the elite and it's a fantastic
controller but we all thought project
washburn you know I'm saying this was
what he was gonna be and when we didn't
hear that that's a disappointment I'm
not kidding I don't care about another
colored version of the old one
you know why console looks good you know
I wish you know again we don't know why
maybe a region it's for issue as far as
the X not being showed there the Y X the
turtle beach's look fired I don't tell
you why but I gotta throw them in the
bushes
you know dolby atmos shout out to so you
know what i'm running you know I'm about
at most life so again none of this stuff
is for me but I am happy about the
console like a true custom color
council that looks clean looks nice it's
just none of this stuff but if you look
at the custom stuff man did you see that
Tomb Raider console yeah dad that's a
custom console like that ya know local
real quick one yin and we move on as far
as this whole white controller rightly
controller console turned out really I
did I don't those bundles those customs
they're not custom those are just some
lame color and we will move on last
topic Lord King
Daisy what's poppin alright I just want
to give you a quick rundown on Daisy
Daisy has launched in game preview now
shout out to jazz grind my gears she was
complaining not too long ago about game
preview games being launched in preview
without giving you a chance to try it
before you buy it and that's one of the
games that give you the try it before
you buy it who did their for you Phil
did that for you understand but this
game has taken and you can group up with
your friends you can meet in the world
with these zombies it's very early
preview the engine is running really
nice my experience with the game is not
a game that I'm gonna purchase at this
point um because it didn't give me that
initial pop I ran in houses I saw
zombies I was completely terrified the
world is like somebody really threw you
in the bushes cuz you're running through
the bushes and there's no lights
sometimes when you're playing at night
it is horrifying
alright um then you got on a couple of
bullets but you gotta eat food you got a
drink water is a survival as a game if
you're into that it's in preview right
now you get one hour to test it out and
I think the game was like twenty nine
dollars and it will get better over time
if anything is any indication pugsy did
it um I just wanted to get that out
there to you guys I really don't want
any feedback on it I want us to end this
show
we are half an hour no I mean Emily I'm
just going because I played it before
you know I'm saying so I just want to
shout out all the dues or from bohemian
anything I won't say this like the kings
in the engine it's fantastic I was
wanted to stand out engines on the X as
far as I start running to one of the
better-looking games there you know so
you know it's out there it's game
preview you know had a chance to check
it out if you haven't seen if you want
to see more on it if you undecided
please check out the ILP YouTube channel
because um I have we have the ID
interview with the dev update as well as
footage plug plug plug go check oh yeah
so that's pretty much what I got on it
but yeah it's in game prove you if
you're into that thing I know people
wait for it to come console by all means
go ahead so if anybody got anything else
one Daisy will move them in this thing
all right all right cool so new poll
this week and it's funny that we got a
code so well before a highly anticipated
triple a game is released how important
our initial negative impressions videos
or articles to you a important devs need
to be honest and held accountable for
footage shown be somewhat important
negative impressions may influence me to
wait on the game see not important I buy
what I want regardless or D I don't care
unless the puddle and the horse Texas is
on fleek Lord of the Lord where could
find people have you find you in what do
you got going on this on Twitter and
optimus underscore code I do I talk
about gaming topics and programming
topics and then you know the couple of
websites that I built and I built those
from scratch because I cannot deal with
YouTube and they restrictions on
language and I think I should get an A
for the day because I don't you
we watch your channel I guess again
salute the auto hunters go be good as
people don't understand what he's like a
beast he's like I'll let you guy don't
know if I'm ready for the realm dizzy I
said bro I get it and I want to commend
you thank you so much for respecting you
know I'm saying the realm and again
still fantastic content the most
dangerous v-log on the net but the man
drops knowledge and like I said when you
check out the game of protocol you don't
say what makes a real game well and just
his his his knowledge is vast knowledge
of what he experienced in the industry
and what's going on in his opinions on
gaming please check it out plug your
site what is it it's real gamer dot life
really and I wanna say man I appreciate
y'all having me on man like I have a lot
of respect for y'all I really do thank
you because uh
y'all y'all have balanced perspectives
y'all have a lot of fun and I just
really respect the brand that y'all
building man I really do I really
appreciate really means a lot coming
from you
yo G man so much respect man and like I
said we're just trying to do this thing
the right way and it's great to have you
know I'm saying people like you any on
the platform because we get to learn a
lot of stuff job so much announced today
chat was definitely loving you there's
no doubt about Lord addict what do you
have going on and what can find people
find you I'm about to release a video
tomorrow I'm not gonna say the name just
gonna let that be a surprise you know
you know catch us weekly uh every Sunday
one by 11 you can catch the IOPS at 11
a.m. and bored addict at 12 thanks out
outs are a wonderful guest here is his
Twitter I will put it in the comment
section definitely go on Twitter yes
very entertaining guy you guys don't
understand what it is like to have a
very r-rated mouth and come on this show
it's not yet he mentioned you to these
are I don't
you wouldn't cuss know y'all planted
Xbox you know that I'm very different on
that one just a little bit definitely
appreciate everyone coming by you know
we have up to like 85 people in here
even cat daddy fat sticks I definitely
appreciate him coming I'm tired
I got a do I need it in this but no keen
wants to correct the Lord stopped online
two weeks in a row let me address the
I'll just dispersed shout out to optimus
code thank you for coming through
brother like really appreciate it man I
always love having gamers that are from
our generation and have the same type of
stories that we that we've lived so I
definitely appreciate you coming through
as for me you can catch me fraud anon
destiny up until puppet I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna be offline anymore you
will see me I'm destiny a man is in my
hands until tomb Raider's in my hands
and then I will disappear as I always do
we are though that's mighty covered like
King in the realm hilarious as always
first and foremost I would like to
salute the og because a lot of stuff
that he talked about y'all didn't if
y'all watch the podcast over again I
want you to please listen very closely
to the gyms that he
dropping and said his daytime life was
very different from his nighttime life
and coming from South Bronx hanging out
with my cousin took me from that
nighttime life and you know we had ei so
when he's saying en he's saying Lakers
versus Celtics and he said you know
stuff like that you know that same page
story yeah it saved people from
different things so I respect and I
salute you 100% when you send me to DM I
usually check this out you know I value
your opinion
let me check it out soon as I checked it
out I hit kognito
I said yo he is probably the most
hilarious dude that I've seen and I
loved it instantly so if anybody is not
watching this channel please get over to
his channel watch this channel right now
Optimus cold is just like y'all hear me
in chat I'm not the same this is for the
kids
alright this arm IOP is for the children
we embrace the king like I said again
salute to Lord cold for it like I said
you know admonishing the code and and
just like I said just something to the
realm of the Lord's and just being being
cool he do is corporate suit on today so
I just we got a lot of things going on
obviously attention you know to Lord
addicts chagrin starting next week the
NFL laws will be switching 11:00 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time probably doing
that to the beginning of the new year
before we switch back to our original
schedule but the Lords must bend the
knee to fantasy football and the NFL
season it's going down next week we got
that and of course um I want to shout
out the stream team real quick again all
over on l-boogie
to the G you know the exact least now
though he our ace listen follow
now though on Twitter y'all this Friday
he's got a giveaway going on he's got
some copies of some games going on
I believe if he hits if you're on Steam
he's giving scum away so it's gonna be
Friday night
he's gonna be doing that 7:00 to 10:00
so please join that stream even if
you're just trying to get the free game
get in that stream and he's doing
giveaways he's gonna be poppin smelled
oh it's all s in a I can put your name
in a yld all follow my Twitter I'll
retweet it on ILP so you guys can catch
that so I'm getting make sure again
subscribe hit like and all that YouTube
I hope you patrons all that good stuff
and obviously our personal IOP our
channel also I'm definitely - I'll talk
about to an audio that's gonna be going
up later tonight including the
timestamps and all that good stuff and
special flash point 30 that was with he
Bonta sand will him scream that was up
on the ILP channel for the latest in
forsaken we getting ready and yeah man
that's all we got
next Sunday 11 a.m. you know to do
anybody got anything else to say before
you're gonna get the the pre-fight you
gotta get what's gonna happen and then
sunday you gonna get the results this is
what I've been waiting for and then
right after that you got triple G vs.
Canelo but this fight is what you are
waiting for if you want to get informed
come check me out I'm gonna put it up
all over the place
Instagram Facebook Twitter the ILP
channel is gonna be all over the place
you're not gonna miss it yeah and one
correction real quick as soon Aldo's
killing me it's on the ILP twitch
channel that is correct again subscribe
to the iron law podcast on twitch that's
where she was going on Friday 7:00 p.m.
to 10:00 and if you gave me information
earliest now that I wouldn't a butcher
[Laughter]
day we are here
[Music]